joining us here in studio already same
thing show your shirt d-wade
you you right there know me zoom in on
me zoom in on it so
this number right here this number is
the number to
kentucky's attorney general you cameron
so you guys can call this number press
one and leave a message
powerful way jury very powerful man the
way you've been coming with the shirts
this week i like that
that's that's special but i i love what
those guys are doing in the bubble
um you know they're standing up for what
they're believe what they believe in
you know i've always said for athletes i
think a lot of times people try to make
it
your obligation you know uh something's
going on you have to speak
and the thing that i love most about
this is
you can tell it's not god's obligation
anymore because of the lengths that
they're going
and so it's not that someone is making
it their obligation
everyone is truly standing for what they
believe in and that's why i think
you know we can really make some change
but i think they got to be very careful
because if he just going to say every
answer that's going to be my answer to
every question they're going to stop
talking to him
i mean you can do both i mean these guys
do have a job to do
because once basketball start they're
going to ask hey what happened this game
what happened here like if he's going to
say i'm not answering any question i'm
just going to say justice phil brianna
taylor
the guy gonna say well why am i gonna
come talk to you everybody you really
think they're gonna stop talking to
somebody like lebron james if he decides
that he's only gonna answer with a
second here you can do both
okay so but what if they don't want to
well then
the press ain't gonna talk to him well i
think i think uh
that just makes the press put out the
narrative that we want to tell because
at the end of the day
the press still has a job to do as well
and if the only thing you can report is
brianna taylor you're not gonna stop
answering questions
because you have to submit your article
to your editor so if these guys continue
to say that
someone's going to have to continue to
write that article but i'm saying dre
you have to do both
because you said you you said it these
reporters they do have a job to do
they have to write something and if
you're not going to answer questions
you got to give them something you want
your opponent across
like i said i'm just they're going to
have to you can do both things
right i think it's important to i think
that's what you said earlier and i
wanted you to explain it it is important
to do both things but what if you don't
feel the need right now because you're
tired and
all you want to do with this moment is
ask for justice yeah but you got to
respect
the media they have a job to do when the
games start
kerry we're gonna have to talk about the
games
and you're gonna have to you can like
say it
it's not it's a very slippery slope but
if you if guys are trying to ask you
basketball questions
you can't say i'm going to just give you
the same answer every time i don't think
that's fair
you're going to have to let them do
their job you know you know one thing
you can do
when you sit down at the press table you
can start
before they ask you any questions you
can actually start and say what you want
to say first
just like the coaches do when coaches go
to the press table they sit and they say
what they want to say so if you want to
say something if you don't want to wear
something that says justice for brianna
taylor you can start it off and
and have a message before you answer the
questions
about basketball and then you can answer
some questions
you got to let them do their job or you
can end every answer
with justice for beyonce
great defense tonight but we still need
justice for yes yes there you go
i'm with that i'm with that 100
meanwhile you know what else
his nickname isn't dre we just made that
up his name is day day
today we just day day and i just be
calling him dre how'd i make that up hey
nasty
respect on that t-shirt they want it i
want it
day day or dre day day okay
we'll be back in a moment folks justice
for brianna taylor